найгірше позаду в Укренерго звітують що
зсередини лютого в енергосистемі України
відсутній дефіцит потужності У багатьох
українських містах більше немає
відключень світла хоча в деяких регіонах
усе ще тривають перебої зі струмом
звідки світло попри руйнування
енергосистеми Які ризики залишаються
скільки Україна імпортує струму і чи
продає власну електроенергію наскільки
зруйнована енергосистема
енергосистема України пережила 14
ракетних і 17 дро
нових більше 50% енергетичної
інфраструктури України зазнали ударів
ідеться і про генерацію і про систему
передачі електроенергії найбільше
пошкоджень у тепловій енергетиці
буквально кожна ТЕС потрапила під удар
теплова найбільше хоча знову ж таки як
це дивитися на сьогодні
окупована Запорізька атомна станція А з
точки зору обсягу генерації вона
найбільша тому вона видавала більше 6000
МВт потужності але ударів дійсно навіть
станції які знаходяться взагалі на
західному кордоні вони так само були
такою
звідки знову світло як повідомляло
Укренерго у лютому Україна вийшла з
дефіциту електроенергії суттє
во завершувались планові роботи не
пов'язані з ракетними ударами абсолютно
ніяк вивели два блоки якби атомних
електростанцій там 1400 МВт в цілому
вийшло 600 МВт не казали Наскільки я
знаю 600 МВт лую електростанції вийшло
там два блоки завершили ремонтувати от
Вам уже 2000 МБ Також через раннє
водопілля на повну потужність
запрацювали ГЕС завдяки використанню
резервів обладнання і поставкам з-за
кордону вдалося оперативно ремонтувати
пошкоджені об'єкти усе це на тлі теплої
зими саме завдяки мінімізації дуже
суттєвої строки ремонту от ми змогли
стабілізувати генерацію в системі тобто
зараз де є там можливі десь обмеження
постачання це виключно через ремонти
мереж але ремонти мереж теж відбувається
постійні основі Тобто ми зараз ми
сподіваюсь дуже швидко усунемо Взагалі
всі перешкоди
українська енергосистема підлаштувалася
до життя під постійними обстрілами
по-перше
по нині краще захищена системами ППО
по-друге кампанія укрнер разом з
генерацією оператором системи розподілу
змогла впроваджувати впровадити нові
методи значить реагування на
обстріли
російськими ракетами і дронами
енергетичної системи і цей метод полягає
саме в розвантаженні енергетичної
системи в період значить які передує цим
атакам і і збереження внаслідок цього
в системі частоти нормативної і
цілісності енергетичної системи у
міністерстві
стві НК
щенок ни скажімо не є класичними
технічними рішеннями відповідно до
встановлених нормативів навіть іноді але
вони працюють і завдяки цьому все
тримається це технічні рішення але
деталі Ну я потім напишу мемуарах
Сподіваюся чи експортує Україна струм
урядовці наголошують що з 10 жовтня 2022
року Україна не продає струм за кордон
це може бути підтверджено в тому числі
тому що будь-яка комерційна операція з
транспортування того чи іншого товару в
тому числі і не виключно електроенергія
або природного газу фіксується органами
митного контролю України та
Європейського союзу водночас на сайті
європейської мережі операторів системи
передачі електроенергії
enso і до якої Україна приєдналася майже
рік тому можна побачити перетоки
електроенергії між Україною і Польщею
Румунією Угорщиною Молдовою і
Словаччиною є певні певні невеличкі
перетоки в ту чи іншу в той чи інший бік
Ну наприклад Україна Там е-е значить в
якій в якийсь час в ту же Словаччину там
чи в Польщу
надала там технічний переток електричної
енергії на рівні там
грубо кажучи три мегавати а потім вона
наприклад цей переток отримала коли вже
наш енергетичній системі все це
знадобилось але це мізерні обсяги
некомерційні обсяги це чиста технічні
притоки для підтримання надійності
енергетичних систем України та енцової
водночас експер
Т ладені українськими компаніями до
жовтня Минулого року не могли бути
скасовані адже війна за документами не є
форс-мажором з іншого боку обсяги
перетоків відзначає експерт не впливали
на дефіцит по всій країні Ти віддаєш
туди електроенергію наприклад Да
наприклад там 500 мегават чи скільки Ну
не 500 там 100 мегават наприклад а потім
тобі віддають 100 МВт ну з іншої сторони
оці твої 100 МВт вони можуть
зарахуватися як комерційний переток
Тобто це вже виключно питання Укренерго
і інсує і я думаю що вони могли тільки
певним чином впливати на поставки
електроенергії в Західному регіоні тобто
івано-франківська Львівська там умовно
Тернопільська область частково там могло
це Вплинути в уряд і кажуть що
комерційний експорт струму в Європу
поновлять коли 100% споживачів в Україні
будуть зі світлом
скільки Україна імпортує електроенергії
нині техні
чного у будь-який час доби уряд
сподівається збільшити цю цифру до двох
гігат таке місто як Київ велике
найбільше в Україні воно має потреби
десь півтора гігати цю повністю покрити
всі свої потреби
імпорт може скласти два гігабата Тому це
достатньо серйозна цифра водночас наразі
за словами міністра енергетики імпорт
електроенергії у країні практично не
потрібен Тому що нема сенсу імпортувати
зараз електроенергію тому що є
відповідно електроенергія всередині яка
забезпечує споживання тому Ну тобто це
опція є але сьогодні і фактично ніхто не
користується що далі
у систему графіки відключення більше не
будуть застосовуватися Ми наразі
плануємо Саме так прожити
прожити як мінімум час до
наступного опалювального сезону там
подивимося
експерти теж дають позитивні прогнози на
найближчий час є у нас перспектива
[музика]
водночас те як Україна готуватиметься до
наступної зими відкрити питання адже
пошкоджене обладнання відновлювати
дорого і довго для
оцей який був вибраний нами з інших
країн так і отриманий він чесно вам
скажу він вичерпаний тобто далі вже нема
де брати що по великому рахунку То це
треба або замовляти і виробляти або
наприклад за
весну там літо і осінь так от цього року
здійснити фантастичну програму от заміни
обладнання на інший тип який можна потім
буде скажімо там заміняти оперативно там
за рахунок там європейських країн там чи
американських в уряді сподіваються нако
пичують великою потужності від одного до
150 МВт ми зараз маємо плани щоб
децентралізація саме генерація тобто щоб
в регіонах була власна генерація яка як
мінімум буде забезпечити критичну Утім
за словами експертів вартість енергії
яку вироблять десятки дрібних
електростанцій буде суттєво вищою за
ціну струму з крупних об'єктів генерації